Gwen Stefani performs a new Christmas  jingle as The Today Show hosts keep  things positive during the Christmas in  Rockefeller Center special the 85th  annual Christmas tree lighting went down  at New York City's Rockefeller Center on  Wednesday night Al Roker Hoda Kotb and  Savannah Guthrie were smiling and in  seemingly good spirits while hosting the  show even though the NBC holiday special  came just hours after their fellow today  host Matt Lauer was terminated following  accusations of quote inappropriate  sexual behavior in the workplace after  over 20 years of employment with NBC  this is a sad morning here at today and  at NBC News Harry Connick jr. pentatonix  Seale and more stars performed keeping  the spirit of beat throughout the show  Gwen Stefani even debuted her new single  my gift is you off her Christmas album  [Music]